first they start forgetting small things
but eventually they forget their entire
life worldwide more than 44 million
people are living with dementia an
incurable brain disorder
Edward Kline was diagnosed five years
ago his wife Martina decided to care for
him at home the disease has progressed
so far that he needs care around the
clock and can no longer speak caring for
him is a challenge
by citizens up the gate my meeting when
I'm trying to get him to open his mouth
like now should I treat him like a child
or like an adult there's always a bit of
wiggle room depending on what he
responds to I'm still able to cope it
was hard to get used to but it had
gradually also signed first Talmud Klein
was confused wandered off and got lost
meanwhile he would starve if his wife
Martina wasn't caring for him he barely
speaks any more often Martina Klein can
only guess at what he might be thinking
or feeling when I'm busy it often seems
like he's bored that might not be true
but I feel like I have to do something
with him he doesn't talk so it's hard to
figure it out if I ask are you bored
he says bored if I ask is everything
okay he says okay
the best isn't good enough amazing I
would miss him if he weren't here but
even with all this there's still these
moments during the day that are happy
again
yeah and well I still love him and I
don't just want him to go into a care
home somewhere
hell root Klein was an executive at a
bank in Berlin he was extremely
organized loved football and hiking and
had many friends he has a particularly
severe form of dementia that can strike
people as young as 50 often it leads to
death within five to eight years there
are ups and downs on some days I'm
alright and I can accept the situation
but then there are days when I feel sad
about it all and then I have phases
where I feel a bit aggressive and think
I can't do this anymore it's not easy
the best way to cope is to just make
sure that you maintain some kind of
daily routine and to live for the moment
darkanian
I don't like to think about what's going
to happen in six months or in a year I
try to just live for today what happens
tomorrow I'll deal with that when it
comes the climbs raised three children
here their two daughters are older and
moved out a while ago just a few days
ago their son also moved out Martina
Klein still shares a bedroom with her
husband sometimes at night she holds his
hand he's incontinent so she has to
change the sheets often although she now
does accept outside help she's still
afraid sometimes that she won't be able
to cope sometimes I feel physically
exhausted or emotionally overwhelmed
both of these things can happen it's
been alright until now when those
moments came up when I was stressed out
and felt overwhelmed the children were
still here they would notice what was
happening and say mom let us take over
for a bit
ma ma Martina often takes out the old
photo albums it's a way of jogging
Helmut Klein's memory to try to help him
remember life as it was sometimes he
responds
oh let's come by for the pause she does
that when he's happy or when he's unsure
about a situation sometimes it seems he
wants to say something
contribute something but can't anymore
it used to be that I was the quiet one I
used to listen more and he was the one
who talked but now I'm the one who has
to talk which isn't always easy for me
but if I don't talk it's completely
quiet so it's up to me in the afternoons
they often play Yahtzee
it's helmet Klein's favorite game he
still loves numbers and every so often
there are small moments of success so I
might spice in defeat it's fine might
spice in yeah hey this surfboard
the next morning they're on the road
early Martina Klein is bringing her
husband to a senior daycare center it
took her a long time but eventually she
realized she couldn't manage on her own
anymore
so three days a week Helmut Klein goes
to the care center
pushing me for the next seven hours
helmet Klein will be cared for here it's
the only time that Martina Klein has to
relax and do something for herself
I enjoy the chance to relax to enjoy the
fresh air social circle does shrink a
bit so you have to make sure that you
don't get too isolated you have to take
care of yourself and make an effort to
maintain friendships whenever you can
the longer the situation continues the
more important it becomes to get some
time to myself 4:00 in the afternoon
Martina Klein picks her husband of then
takes him home the system in the outer -
- I mean it is tough stuff on TV on tape
Samia so Aldrin gets pizza
- it's fine oh yeah a super lap dog
yeah the Kleins younger daughter is
visiting you Leone is studying sports
therapy at University she deliberately
chose to stay in nearby Potsdam so she
can help out at home for a long time
Yulia didn't tell her friends about her
father's dementia meanwhile she talks
about it openly and she admires her
mother's strength at first I felt
overwhelmed when I had to watch him for
a bit or when he ran off and I didn't
know what to do and my mother does this
every day Kim talked even though my
father isn't really sorry it's kind of
hard for me to talk about it she's
always trying to help everyone and still
give as much love as she can and take
care of him even though she has to deal
with all the stress she still tries to
make life as normal for us as she can
and she supported us when it came time
for us to move out as hard as it was for
her the clients usually spend the
evening in front of the television
Elwood Klein enjoys watching nature
shows back when he was healthy the
client's used to go hiking a lot
Martyna doesn't know how long she'll be
able to keep caring for her husband at
home her husband's illness has taught
her to take every day as it comes she
has one wish for the future oh my hope
is that we can spend what time we have
together in relatively good health and
that we can still do nice things
together all together as a family
confident and have as many good days as
possible solution a darker